it never made sense for Evangelical
Republicans to support Donald Trump it
never made sense and so now use whatever
phrase you like the chickens are coming
home to roost what goes around comes
around the bill is come do whatever this
was a sort of Faustian pact all along
for the evangelicals they really didn't
like Hillary they sort of wanted Ted
Cruz and then that didn't work out and
Trump called Ted Cruz's wife ugly and
things didn't go well and ultimately
they had Trump or Hillary as their
choice
um and then it was Trump or Biden and
Biden's Catholic and a lot of
evangelicals don't like that either and
so they went with Trump overwhelmingly
but it never made sense look at Trump's
past Behavior look at Trump's past
statements the extramarital affairs uh
the profanity the um you know way that
he has talked about women in the past it
doesn't align with what the evangelicals
want us to believe other Christian
values